we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
oh
hell here we are it's the holiday season
in new york there's a nip in the air
thanksgiving's over christmas is on the
way and hanukkah
so uh we're really doing it good to see
you just like the country you just slid
hanukkah right in there
thought we wouldn't notice no i'll tell
you this is my favorite stretch man that
uh yes in new york it's like it's
getting a little cold but this is when
we're still happy to see the cold right
right it's not march when we're [ __ ]
you know a beating housewife in the 50s
please just say stop right yeah it's
like when my dad comes home you're like
dad then 20 minutes in he's like [ __ ]
a piece of [ __ ] you failed out of school
you know your mom hates you and you're
like jesus so yeah that's where we're at
no it's it's still nice
i mean we're doing hot cocoa today this
is perfect wholesome
with a with a splash well
it wouldn't be we might be drunk
without a little bit
of grandpa's old cough what kind are we
using we're going with a nice uh
kentucky bourbon all right
well i just ruined the uh tablecloth
tell me when
whoa oh all right
i feel like cosby
we're putting our viewers to sleep
what kind of a bourbon was that again
key west or highways
what is it basil hay this is good stuff
basil hayden there's a good stuff all
right i think uh pete davidson [ __ ]
her
[Music]
basil hayden
i think that's bieber's wife hayden
oh that's really good with the bourbon
oh yeah yeah
oh
yeah the sweet with this that kick at
the end i love it almost like a
peppermint patty a little bit yes
remember those were you ever like a
junior mince peppermint patty type of
guy i mean neither to me was like an
adult yes
people who like mint chocolate chip ice
cream you're just like yeah that had a
run in the 90s for a while and i hate it
i kept my head down it's like eating
toothpaste it was like cargo shorts yeah
like this is this is in from it's not
going to last exactly yes it's the
hoverboard it's a spinja it's all
available
all right skater boy
i'll see you later boy
it was uh i was never i i like the new
like if we're doing like birthday cake
ice cream i'll [ __ ] i'll get down a
little chocolate chip cookie dough sure
is ice cream your go-to dessert yeah i
like it too but i will say when cookie
cake came out i [ __ ] the bed i mean that
blew my mind yeah the fat the flat
cookie wait with frosting on it says
happy birthday sam oh man i love cookie
cake cookie cake is good so good
remember ice cream cake ice cream cake
was pretty big
wow that was like when the ipod came out
my mom always tried to be healthy with
it because she loved remember tasty
delight that was like a real new york
thing my parents my dad [ __ ] loved
that was like
my dad must have been killing hookers or
something because
because i mean
his worst vice was like like a scoop of
like tasty delight i'm like how are you
you have like half a salmon right right
i'm like how is this the bad thing you
do that can't be enough yeah he's matt
lauer on the weekends but uh during the
day but you know those tasty delight ice
cream cakes those were that place was
cool though cause you could go in and
just go sample after you they wouldn't
stop you from getting like four samples
it's true is that the one where you you
do it yourself no that's 16. oh sorry
what's tasty delight it was it was like
pre pink berry
pinkberry had a run oh big run did tcby
go out of business that was big when i
was back yeah
dude
the country's best yogurt oh
i never knew that it was good yeah
pinkberry's like [ __ ] charlie sheen
it was it was up here for a minute and
then went right back down too many porn
stars you got aids
by the way how's that
you get aids now and it's like a news
story and then you're fine
are you fine though
i think he's all right i mean uh magic
johnson's meeting and greeting yeah but
he's so rich yeah maybe you got to be
rich i mean when he got it everyone was
like he's dead oh yeah i mean i remember
car malone in the nba was like i'm not
playing with him i know really
yeah that does not also carmelone had
sex with a 13 year old and impregnated
her i think so i'm looking that up
because yeah
look it up i stand behind it wow he'd be
in jail right
i don't know dude man
that's a slam dunk
13 year old that's a foul
oh yep there it is a little forward
i ain't wrong statutory rape
magic johnson though that was like do
you ever see that doc the 30 for 30 on
magic no that's one of the best ones
really really good about the aids or oh
yeah oh [ __ ] oh yeah all right i lost a
lot of money on that aids
i bet against him
yeah brutal i thought he had like a
two-year window fanduel that's what it
is
this is really good this is great my
go-to hot winter
see i'm like down for an art bag or like
a pd winter scotch
love petey
if you're doing like a man we did that
hot toddy episode those are [ __ ] nice
dude i'm a sucker for all these like
eggnog i can do a gallon of eggnog i
mean you [ __ ]
you know bile but man i love an eggnog
with bourbon i'm hurting i i did uh that
chinese food place we went to that
tonight i order there sometimes it's
man that is just diarrhea city oh yeah
yeah which i think is a town in wuhan
where it all began yeah and
you know no it really uh
it's really good that place i got who
got the fish and the chili sauce holy
[ __ ] that's one of the best things i've
ever they bring in the whole big thing
yeah that's an event
as you're eating it you ever eat
something you're like this is gonna be
terrible tomorrow you just that should
be the on the outside the restaurant is
like worth the diarrhea is what it
should say
because you know it's coming it's
horrible chinese food in the cold is not
much better it's when winter time
new york ah
so good is that your number one winter
food
it's probably up there i mean
americana is nice too like comfort food
lasagna uh rice and gravy and you know
[ __ ] like that pot roast that's good too
but chinese something about it hot and
sour soup dumplings
forget about it something spicy chicken
[ __ ] like that oh man that's like that
just you your whole body warms you they
have mamoons right by the cellar they do
a lentil soup oh it's great in the
winter that [ __ ] comes in a little cup
it's like 375. can't beat it you ever go
to woe hop back in the day what's that
yeah you know about whoa
dive hole in the wall walk down the
stairs you got to go downstairs it's
open till 5 a.m so we'd all get drunk
after the bar
yeah it was a big uh institution on
march street march street
everything was like eight cents it was
so cheap you lived like a king in wohop
cash only i think so yeah it was under
the table i think they were on the up
there they are that's how they served
you yeah whoa hop there
some guy tried to venmo me for he was
like he's got him in cash i'll venmo you
i'm like what do you think it's my first
day here in new york do you think i'm
gonna get con this easily
i overpaid you can you send me the money
back then you find it it's one of those
scams wait is that a restaurant no
that's oh and the moon because it's cash
only oh
right
those cash only places like it's weird
now because you kind of have to
ma moons is not a place you plan on
going at the beginning of the night it's
a place you end up so it's weird that
those places are cash only yeah cause
cash is
people aren't really caring anymore no
and we need to come together because you
go to some place it's hey we're sweet
green cashless we're the future cashless
then you go there and it's all cash no
card we got to come together yeah
it's getting hard also even with the
subway now you do the uh the tap the tap
i kind of like it man i love the tap
it's easy although i get i get declined
a lot more with the credit card tab
no i don't get it really no what's going
on with the finances
come on it just it takes a while to read
sometimes oh okay do you ever i oh i
gotta pee for you i'm on the subway
today uh-oh and
it's pretty crowded there's a woman with
the bag on the seat oh yeah totally
coveted i don't blame her though it's
like i'm saving this seat for the holy
spirit like don't sit next to me don't
you feel like she was that person before
covert
i don't think she all of a sudden became
the i i get a a a seat from my bag
the bag seat lady's been around since
eternity yeah she's always been there
and i hate the bag sometimes you give
her a look she's like
you know she makes a big scene out of
taking the bag off like she's a [ __ ]
mother teresa all of a sudden but here's
what you do if you want to be that
person you you put your butt crack in
between the two seats oh that way it's a
little more sneaky that's a sneaky way
to do it that's a real new yorker right
there i'll tell you what i don't love is
you go to every bar and restaurant and
everybody's got their coat and scarf and
bag on a chair you're like
what this coat is having a better life
than me it's on a chair i'm standing
you're outside banging on the window
yeah freezing dude i'll tell you these
bulky winter coats you got to get
yourself a thin coat i do i do layers
i'm i'm rocking the uniqlo layers bro i
do layers too i gotta get a long sleeve
on under this love it love the layers
lovely you ever put on a long john then
jeans over it you feel like you're
beating the system do you think that you
ever put on a long john i'm wearing them
right now
i love long johns and people say it's a
little early in the season not for me
the only problem with the long john is
you go to fool around later and your
dick smells like a stovetop stuffing i
mean it's just been cooking and
marinating in that heat and then spagma
and the cheese and the pubes and i keep
bread down there anyway so you know we
got a yeast infection
but yeah it's just you're baking bread
down there all night and you're running
set
subway stairs
it's a little ecosystem i walked in i
walked in uh
you know in my long johns and my uh my
uniqlo heat tech top and my girlfriend
told me i look like an old prospector
that's true yeah
uh
you're fanning for gold
so is there a poop shoot on those no
poop shoot no but there's a fly for your
penis which is more than i can say for
those shitty underwear with no flap you
got all that on you yeah call him out
yes get a flap going this is this is
america this is quality i could do this
more often we just fell ass backwards
into this and it's it's kicking out and
this is real milk hot cocoa none of that
[ __ ] i hate when you get a water
oh yeah come on that's what they were
serving to jews in nazi germany oh my
you got that right
here's your ration for the day
hot water with a little powder
yeah that swiss miss was a real
anti-semite well you could do the swiss
smith with with uh milk couldn't you
this yeah that's true that's sweet or
neutral though swiss are neutral that's
true and another nothing but a couple of
those marshmallows oh just the little
ones marshmallows are good yeah cause
you get the big ones and they suck up
all the cocoa
we talked about the extra thick hot
cocoa i hate it you can't drink it can't
drink it it's a syrup it's a it's a
puree of just chocolate you just you
just melted chocolate yeah it's lazy
it's lazy you're showing off but really
you're taken away right i'm eating cake
frosting over here at this point yeah
although which i i could do cake for
austin well
i mean i talked about diarrhea
it comes out the same way
you might as well [ __ ] over a cookie
cake
spell something oh i shouldn't the
toilet says happy birthday
happy birthday nana
sorry about the corn
[Laughter]
what about corn and dessert how do you
feel about that like some ice cream
places i think they're getting a little
carried away and you'll get like a corn
ice cream i hate it it's crazy get out
of here
yeah well they're getting too uh
too experimental yeah you know some guy
made a cronut 10 years ago and he was
got pat on the back
you're not dominic anzor whatever the
hell his name was you're not you're some
dude who [ __ ] got carried away we
don't need
you get lucky every once in a while we
don't need this many avant-garde
desserts
yes there's a classic the classic for a
reason it's like when that [ __ ] puts the
uh
you know the the raisins in the coleslaw
like what are we doing here
raisins and chicken salad are too buggy
i'm not a fan yeah you're ruining a good
thing
it does look like bugs i don't like it
yeah i'm not big on the the crow nut is
i mean that type of [ __ ] i mean i never
had it rip city bakery that spot
remember that it's chloe street it's
closed that well they had the the
pretzel croissant which was like
that was i mean
there was nothing better yeah you get a
pretzel croissant you put the every it's
got the everything seasoning on it oh
yeah
game changer you know i used to live in
the east village in that moishes bakery
and it would get a brick thrown through
the window every now and then it would
get spray painted it's still there why
why would it get a brick i don't know i
think cause it was the only glass it was
like old school glass with moistures and
i think people just you know you get
bored it's a pretty
pretty uh sign look up moishes if you
can on second avenue man that looks so
good oh that's good stuff
yeah i've heard about it i don't think
i've ever been there yeah it's an old
jewish bakery and it the food was great
it looked cool it was tile floor and all
that [ __ ] but uh still there
you know second avenue delhi went away
oh yeah the new delhi kind of sucked
though oh there it is wait is that it
that's it that's a corner place i don't
know if that's it oh that's not it
you're right that's not it dude the
second avenue deli kind of sucks
really it's so overpriced you get like a
i'll tell you this like all right maybe
i'm being hard on it but like cats just
blows it out of the [ __ ] water
doesn't it yeah am i wrong i thought
cats
place cass's delicatessen blows out of
the water second avenue 100
yeah really yeah
there it is see all the graffiti but it
just keeps fighting second avenue delia
to me is like you get a soup there it's
like nine dollars and it sucks damn
i think they're like they'll have like a
good lot cursing but the sandwiches are
like okay it's nothing in comparison to
katz's or like barney barney greengrass
or those types of plays yeah i'll take
cats over almost any place other than
carnegie jelly which clothes the
carnegie deli was dope it was pickles
yeah but katz's has that winter canish
dude
it's just called a kanish but in the
winter it's [ __ ] yeah even the hot
dogs there what's in a connection potato
it's just like a fried potato but it's
crazy good and you put a little mustard
on it fried mashed potato yeah that's so
good
sounds like an old guy who lives above
you yeah you got to keep it down win old
man winter kanesh
sounds like an orthodox jewish punk band
yes
yeah yeah see all these other places you
know i don't think they have jewish uh
bakeries and delis like this i love them
yeah they're classic oh yeah and they
feel like home something about man i
just drink way too much coffee oh what
are you all in there that's a shot geez
carnegie deli
and who was the first guy to say that a
vagina looked like cold cuts that guy
needs a high five
somebody doesn't think of it
woody allen he said it looks like a like
a cold couple when he gets to the very
bottom and it's tiny
he can't make a movie now no
he's done he's doing a youtube special
what's next
woody allen's youtube a youtube movie
although his his youtube movie is going
to be starring javier bardem
like holy [ __ ] man it's pretty
impressive right scarjo is in it
if he did a comedy album though how cool
would that be his early comedy album is
incredible unbelievable great jokes they
still hold up they're like evergreen
he wrote for sid caesar when he was like
18.
yeah he was something crazy he was like
absolutely a prodigy
his body of work i mean it's pretty
crazy but like
man until you get to the
early 90s and it gets yeah kind of rough
and i'm talking about the movies ah do
you want to hear a joke we won't get uh
kicked off because it's just audio sure
what allen joe yeah
yeah so he got it in there he he also
has a joke that every comic does now and
it's like a standard woody allen joke
about
you know these machines are taking over
my job i don't have a job anymore
uh one of them is this little thing it
does all the things i can do but better
my wife got one and she dumped me or
whatever it is but it's like a vibrator
joke that a lot of comics kind of do
and he did it
seven sixty years ago or whatever wow
yeah i mean he was a great he was he
would have been a legendary stand-up but
he had he wanted to do other stuff yeah
yeah a lot of people get out of comedy
it's sad you gotta love it you gotta be
a psycho yeah but also maybe this was
you know for the best for i mean he made
great movies so true i read his book
when i started doing comedy without
feathers
biography oh yeah yeah but i did read
about that one too but uh the biography
i was just trying to learn everything i
could about stan about so into it and he
would puke before every performance and
that meant a lot to me i was like this
guy this legend was nervous he had
horrible stage fright
loved that a lot of l.a actresses did
the same trick
yeah
uh but uh he had some great um my wife
says i'm so immature she would come in
the uh
the tub or come in the bathroom while i
was bathing and she would sink my boats
yeah yeah my uncle's uh
he's a reformed jew i mean really reform
he's a nazi
wow he's got a million of them that's a
great joke before
mike kaplan used to have a great joke we
said you know i'm uh
i'm jewish i'm i'm not uber jewish i
will use german to describe how jewish i
am
that's like a woody allen joke that's
like a great that's great yeah yeah
kaplan's got a couple where you're like
jesus yeah that's next level for sure
check out mike kaplan he's got about 38
albums mike spelled my q not a joke
that's how he spells mike myq
kaplan yeah a lot a lot of hilarious
jokes oh yeah smart guy funny guy what
uh you've been on the road i've been on
the road while i was in new orleans
family was great great time went to a
pelicans game did you really yeah who
they play uh
a shitty team hold on well the pelicans
are a shitty team i know they want did
zion play no and ingram didn't play
either he played ingram played he was
the he was the highlight yeah he's good
what did they play
washington
the wizards yes oh the wizards are good
this oh well they weren't that night
they were [ __ ] up and we were drunk
in the stands cheering on
uh they almost threw me out like lebron
i was like you hope your kid dies
by the way did you see that lebron thing
yeah that was crazy apparently they were
saying i hope your kid dies so he's like
you're out you're out that's what did it
wow so everybody's like ron's a [ __ ]
he's a snitch and i'm like wow that's a
little shitty that's what they were
chanting
it was just to a couple and they were
very specific they're like i hope he
dies in the car wreck and they were
describing the car wreck gee
and he's like
whatever happened to boo i know whatever
happened to just booing a team exactly
crazy that's heavy the next that's what
give the knicks fans credit like
they would troll trae young they would
just their chant would be trey is
balding
that you keep it surface you keep it
like
your kids
i mean those are two just sick people
yeah and then she did the cry leave
which was pretty funny but uh man hope
your kid dies and then everybody online
trashed him but i'm like that's kind of
fair
yeah a little over the line
damn yeah there was a you know jay
williams uh jason remember the guy he
shot a chauffeur
oh yeah yeah jason williams by the way
jason williams used to play for the new
jersey nets he was the leading rebounder
for a couple years great rebounder his
sister got murdered when he was in i
think high school college so there was
people chanting at games like your
sister's dead like that type of [ __ ]
[ __ ] horrible like disgusting people
and he got drunk one night and was like
took out his shotgun and killed a
chauffeur by accident i think
he was showing him the gun and flipping
it around and he shot him yeah and then
he covered it up yeah it later became
known as the bold one but uh he
no he uh he he shot him and uh i
remember i met him in a bar in brooklyn
once i was like [ __ ] i was like
hammered and we chat for a while i was
like you're jay jason williams shotgun a
beer
[Laughter]
they were just shooting the [ __ ]
but uh
we talked for a while and he's he ended
up giving me his email and i lost it but
i was like i should invite this guy to a
show
holy [ __ ] he's like hold my gun for a
second
he's like i'll get my driver
wow shot is chauffeur man yeah crazy
terrible terrible story wild why isn't
there a 30 for 30 on that that would be
a good one that guy's life is crazy he
was a great player i mean he was like
you know really just like a
you know
he was a bruiser right it was a very big
yeah okay like it kind of like did what
rodman did a little bit right
at all yeah yeah damn no finesse but
tough
yeah [ __ ] dead sister chant i mean
that's what these roasts have become you
know you watch a roast battle now and
it's like your dad got cancer and your
mom's gay and he got hit by a car and
all this you're like we're really up in
the ante if i want that i'll just log on
to twitter it's crazy it's getting so
aggressive where you're like i don't
want to i i like the the roast where you
kind of it's like your friends and
you're just silly and you can feel the
love with it right exactly that's what
it's supposed to be and it's weird to
roast someone and have to google let me
google you let me ask your friends for a
[ __ ] like he was molested in seventh
grade all right let's go here we go
exactly yeah too dark that's where
they're at now yeah you gotta keep
because if you don't say about them
they'll say about you so you might as
well
dina might have the best roast joke of
all time i remember that one it was dark
as hell you want to tell sally have you
heard it no
dave kinney who's a funny guy his mother
tragically died in a uh
in a motorcycle accident on the highway
in the highway so she goes she died the
way dave lives an unrecognizable road
feature
but you're like that it's a great joke
you're kind of like you want to subject
yourself to that yeah it's like it's a
lot yeah
man that's good i think it went viral
yeah it's a great joke great but you're
also like the dude's mom is dead right
you know it's likely too tragically yeah
he took it like a champ though he was
like
well done
yeah but you know
i know that i think that's why comics is
getting it's funny that we just started
by talking about like lebron like that's
[ __ ] up that this is funny
but this but this actually happened well
they signed up for it yeah that's that
is true he didn't sign up for that he
signed up for a basketball game
but yeah there is a line i think with at
these games where it's like people like
well they're making this much money i'm
like we still don't talk about their
kids dying like that's [ __ ]
you keep it you suck if you want to go
there i know and if i was lebron it'd be
like that jerk store moment like i would
have to find out who these people are go
to their job and be like oh this is why
your dad is a handicap you know just get
them back that would bother me that we
don't know who they are
he just has to live with that that kid
dead thing from these two nobodies
yeah the pistons also suck so those fans
are [ __ ] angry oh is that detroit
people yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah that was that was crazy that game
the bloody the dude just covered in
blood isaac
you didn't see that oh no
pull it up i think his name is isaiah
stewart he's like he's like a tough type
of player and uh
i mean the pistons are they're young
they'll be good in a few they got this
kid cade cunningham who's going to be
sick but you know all right all right
well who won
i think the lakers won all right well
good then the other they did and they
played again a few days ago and lakers
won again
are we allowed to even play this no no
oh [ __ ] we got a brew
this is what you were talking about
isn't it no i didn't see this smack we
play this
all right we got the okay from the
producer oh
baby he's pissed so lebron gave him a
fist across the face and cut his eye
open whoa we got a melee cooking
so that he he he calms down right
wait this is ridiculous man he's pissed
wait to see him go after lebron here
holy hell
so he calms down now he's gonna all
right oh that's a hell of a hit he's
bleeding profusely from the right eye
i'm cool i'm cool i'm cool i'm cool let
go let go let go i'm cool
oh
he ran back out i love it
yeah
look at this guy he's gonna play
football he's blowing through the line
there he's like a tough guy holy hell is
he going after lebron
oh [ __ ]
detroit does not [ __ ] around
i'll be there this weekend
michigan michigan royal although this we
have another episode coming out first
[ __ ] you're right it's already over
thanks detroit
oh yeah great club great town royal oak
right on the outskirts i always go into
detroit get the coney island dog
[ __ ] yeah you gotta see the city damn
you're better than me
yeah it's a 15-minute uber yeah maybe
i'll go with the feature
yeah i had a good time with devito i
yeah i have a good time there man i like
the city yeah good city good club and
it's a boozy it's like a drinking town i
think it's a college there in royal oak
yeah it's like a nice city it's a nice
suburb it is
um
yeah michigan's got a lot of that i'll
be in charlotte you know what i got a
[ __ ] other pee for you dude oh hit me
fatty a lot of hotels in certain cities
like you go to like charlotte you go to
like columbus so certain cities
they don't have any really good hotels
so
the uh
they jack up the prices on the shitty
hotels
so now you're paying like 400 a night
for a marriott weird and you're like
what the [ __ ] might as well pay 450 and
get a nice sheridan or something yeah i
mean it's annoying so certain cities are
like that i don't get it i didn't know
that so how come you guys don't airbnb
it's like 200 bucks for a whole house i
don't i got the club to pay for it uh
i'm not i'm not uh because i usually i'm
taking buyouts now i gotta do this
buyout thing you gotta you you i mean
because you just some of these hotels
you're like i know you got it's it you
just have a better weekend you just like
i'm gonna write better i'm gonna you
know i'm not saying anywhere fancy but i
mean
and sometimes they're far away sometimes
they're on the highway oh man the
ultimate insult was when you were a
young comic and they put you in a total
[ __ ] and it was like 35 minutes yeah
crap
so you went out yes crackers in
indianapolis
it was like a 35 minute drive
and it was a dump yeah so i'm like this
hotel is gross as [ __ ] and it's you're
giving me an hour plus round trip for
the gig tonight yep brutal i know the
worst just cheap clubs cutting corners
yeah hooked up with a waitress of that
club you know 10 years ago and uh even
her she was driving and she's like where
the [ __ ] is this place what are you
doing to me i'm like i know i know
yeah exactly we got halfway there
but tough tough sledding because you
know you're you're ready to go to the
gig and you have to leave an hour early
and then you come home you get home an
hour late you know also you're doing
morning press while you're there
and then also like you trap you a lot of
travel on top of this you're like just
put me [ __ ] downtown i know so then
at some point like give me a buy out and
i'll book the hotel right now also use
it to play better places and they stop
pulling [ __ ] like that i mean we were
young comics that was like where are you
at on uh
on the morning radio did you ever do bob
and tom they hated me really they always
hated me i've never set up punch i know
they still hated me so it was kind of
special i mean i remember i did it once
and uh they i couldn't get a word and
there was that other guy yeah chick i
think it's like kind of surly yeah and i
think i caught him in one of his moods
and he was just annoyed yeah i was like
all right what if i was young and then
the next time this was a big gig not big
gig but it was you could get some ears
on that thing back in the day i don't
think anymore but like berbiglia nick
griffin and tommy john again they all
had like a following from bob and tom i
know so it was kind of i think podcasts
kind of killed it a little oh yeah but i
do
but i do i remember i did the next time
and uh i told a story and i'm like i
know it's gonna clean but i'm like they
set me up for something and i couldn't
think of a clean way to go with it so i
told a story about getting jacked off in
a town car
and i could just see them like
and then as i'm out he went to break and
he was like that could have been a that
could have been a fine for 150 grand in
every market or something like that for
what you just said and i'm like how many
markets he's like 13 i'm like yeah i
just cost you two million that's what
happened that story cost you like grow
up right right come on they loved it
they loved holding that power over the
young nobody that could have cost us 100
it was it was one of the things i'm like
all right dude and you unloaded in a
town car like jay williams
i didn't hit the driver
thank god the partition was up
are there any like uh cities you go to
you're like i really wish i could get on
this show in the morning
but like
is it like that was one there was one
and there was a something in philly that
was big preston and steve they're cool
though they're cool they're really cool
it's funny i just watched it it's always
sunny in philadelphia and they're on it
the whole thing was like you know they
won a prize to get to shoot uh a shot uh
at the flyers game yeah so they call in
to them and then they're there
presenting it to him
it's pretty it's a nice little philly
cameo that's great see that's one thing
i know it's nostalgia and i'm a boomer
and all that [ __ ] but like podcasts are
great we're doing one right now but
there was something special about going
to chicago or philly and being like i'm
on the [ __ ] main thing in this town
like everybody listen to that preston
and steve
it's still i think it still does pretty
well okay it's almost like a howard
stern in each city yeah i know it's
they're the guys they're the guys so
it's pretty cool and then uh
yeah there's something about like i'm
doing an appearance that's kind of yes
yes it'd be nice if every podcast could
do that like now i go to nashville and i
do theo's pod i do nate bergatzi's pod
and then you go to this town you're like
oh this guy's living here now it's kind
of nice feels like the same [ __ ]
yeah but they're almost they're not that
spread out i mean you go to austin you
can do something yeah but there's not
one in like sioux falls
you know
although that's what like radio probably
still helps
yeah those places i don't know maybe not
i think they still listen to the radio
for sure yeah some of those cities
you're like well you're like 10 minutes
behind or 10 10 years behind i mean yeah
so you're like this will be
right well you know what the radio is
like this is maybe as a stretch of an
analogy but like back when you were on
tinder and you're kind of like who cares
no thanks shut up get out of here [ __ ]
you but if you met that girl at a bar it
might be exciting and then you started
flirting and it's kind of like finding a
song on the radio you know when you're
on your itunes you're like ah no thanks
no thanks whatever but if you find a
song on the radio you're like oh this is
kind of special yeah nowadays more
people will hear about the girl in the
bar than you on one of those morning
shows yeah good point good point but uh
yeah i know you mean you know you hear
something on the radio you heard a
million times like oh [ __ ] it's uh
where am i at what is it uh do you
believe in love well you would skip that
all day on spotify
in the car alone at 2 a.m you know
you're like woo this is fun
yeah it's kind of like the fat chick
that it's like similar
it's similar to like uh
channel surfing yes
[Music]
it's like i'm like i don't want to watch
the office on a streamer but you know
anymore i've seen it so many times but
then you you cash on comedy center and
you're like that's kind of fun i don't
know what episode it's like
you forget like pandora is like
that is kind of the excitement of
flipping when you're not hot i don't
have cable at home anymore i just i just
have like every streamer flipping this
song about flipping chris rock claims
that the reason his special blew up was
because they would play on comedy center
at like 2 a.m and people come home from
the bar like who's this guy and then we
got a new audience
interesting if he didn't have hbo he
also was on snl i mean he was on a lot
of stuff true true but there were way
less avenues you know there was no
netflix no that's true yeah comedy
central was big big i mean it made gaff
again it was like beyond the pale was
like huge
crazy speaking of comedy central did you
watch the south park covet space i did
yeah cause you told me to okay you
mentioned watch it it was good it was
funny i mean they got 900 mil from
paramount plus i heard
well that that includes a couple of
movies ten movies i think ten was like
an hour movie does this count as a movie
yeah i think oh okay okay i see it's
funny it was good i thought it was
really funny yeah i mean uh
it was yeah it was i mean it's all of
them as adults so
oh that's great hartman the best part is
that carmen has become a rabbi
so he's got a jewish wife and cute kids
and co and like kyle he's being nice to
kyle now he's like i've changed but i
was like
you did this to troll me
so he thinks his whole life is a troll
kyle and you're kind of just waiting for
him to reveal that he is ah that's great
it's good it's funny some of the stuff
some of the kobe jokes you're like i've
heard this i've heard but like what
about uh jimmy being the host of a late
night the woke that by the way i had a
bit about that it's funny can you tell
us your man well they do the whole joke
with jimmy and it's like i'm not saying
it's like a super original bit but it's
from it was in i got this it's like from
a couple of years ago and the joke his
whole joke is like every he's like jimmy
fallon in the future or kim or whatever
he's jimmy it's late now with jimmy and
every joke just has a woke turn uh-huh
he's like how about you hear about these
mexicans and then it would just be like
uh they're lovely people who uh have a
wonderful and uh
exciting culture like that's their
workers they're hard workers that's
every turn
my bit i mean it's not the same bit
exactly but i had a bit where it was
like um
i would say you know you know those the
best friend in the 80s it's a it's a
different bit it's kind of saying the
same thing but it was like you know and
i'm not accuse them of taking it at all
i'm not [ __ ] saying that at all i
know they're not that's not what they do
you want your 90 million don't you i
want my 900 million 900 900. no but no
my bit was uh
it was like you know in every sex comedy
you'd have that sleazy best friend it's
a different bit
how every uh
best friend would be like did you [ __ ]
her last night oh you didn't lose her
and my bit was like in the future
they're gonna have to make a uh awoke
best friend for these movies did you get
laid last night i was like now we just
talk and he's like well sometimes the
conversation is even more fulfilling so
that's pretty cool
that was the bit yeah so it's like it's
that type same type of thinking but it's
not you know hey we might be drunk is
brought to you by honey the holidays are
right around the corner so save yourself
the stress and find the best prices with
the click of a button no matter what
you're shopping for online honey wants
you to find a sweet deal we love honey
we buy a lot of stuff online
clothing
uh you name it food booze whatever it is
and it's all there and there's always a
deal and honey helps you get that deal
here's the move honey is the free
browser extension that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one and finds it for your cart it's
simple when you check out the honey
button drops down and all you have to do
is click apply coupons wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons it
can find for that site if honey has fine
if honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch the prices drop honey's found over
17 million members
over two billion dollars in savings holy
[ __ ] tell them how to do it sammy if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing on free savings it's
literally free and installs in just a
few seconds and by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a solid and supporting
this podcast get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
drunk that's join honey dot com slash
drunk hell yeah we might be drunk is
also sponsored by bowling branch a
better sleep starts with better sheets
and bowling branches help
you
be able to sleep straight through
2022.
i like these guys you know the lady
loves a nice sheet so does the clan you
put it on your bed you sleep great
that matters when what what do you spend
more in than your bed we're not in a car
we're not on the couch that much we
don't have a recliner like my
grandfather you're in your bed every
night for eight hours if you're lucky so
spend the money it's worth it you're
there all the time bowling branches
signature hem sheets are their all-time
bestseller these babies get softer with
every single wash come in a wide range a
wide variety of colors
sizes and are completely toxin free and
fair trade certified too and it's not
just their sheets that are made the
right way their pillows bath towels and
robes are very soft you'll be taking
extra naps just to cup a feel tell them
how to do it i'm getting softer with
every single wash
treat yourself and your loved ones to
the new standard in bedding from bowling
branch their gifts come wrapped and
ready in their special holiday packaging
ordered by december 19th for guaranteed
delivery by christmas get 15 off on your
first set of sheets with uh promo code
drunk at bowlingbranch.com that's
b-o-l-l and branch dot com promo code
drunk yes
yeah yeah what i'm trying to say is i
deserve that 900 million and uh no i
love those i think they're really the
best i really like they really are they
really are geniuses they're
they got grandfathered in that kind of
couldn't get cancelled and they're
animated they're animated but the fact
that they start in the 90s and it's
still the same show kind of helps to
make them uncancelable i mean look
anyone being canceled over jokes is a
[ __ ] it's a joke anyway sure sure
yeah i think louie got nominated for
anne chappelle and kevin hart
and nate parkotsi yeah fun fact angeline
maxwell so
but it's funny i do hear people talking
about her being like like she's cancer
i'm like no she broke the law there's a
this is not cancer culture some of her
friends are like it's it's cancelled
coach i'm like she's on trial this is
not
there's a difference between right i'd
like to hear her material i hear it's
about 15 years old
but yeah does she kind of do it for you
or am i not she's attractive
[Laughter]
uh
you know presidents it's so funny
you're not wrong that she's like look
she comes from royalty she comes from
tragedy as well i think her father
killed himself oh it was the whole thing
she's lived but all but it's so funny to
describe her as worldly yeah she's
worldly man she's been all over the
globe young julian was was hot yeah i've
never seen you know she is right there i
don't know
that's a pretty lady if that was your
friend's mom you'd be like hey hey you
can uh put me on a massage table
all right
excuse me that hot cocoa really bubbles
up oh yeah
is that her is that her i think it must
be her dad pretty solid i'm gonna say
it's a guy from bar rescue
that was john taffer it looks like him
oh i wonder what he'd say about her bar
um yeah she uh
yeah she really not a good person oh
john tapper that guy's the best
guy he's he's like uh angry brad garrett
ah
you nailed it
raven you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] i don't
take your liquor license this is a
disgrace i hear he's a great guy brad
garrett that's what i've heard too yeah
he's an awesome dude owns a comedy club
in vegas sweet guy michael our putty
michael somerville who works loves him
yeah brett garrett looks like smart
michael cohen
yeah he does he does look he looks like
intellectual uh michael cohen there yeah
i can't get him all at the same time
yeah michael uh michael cohen that guy
keeps funny i see him in like a rangers
hat and it's funny when you see a guy
like michael cohen rocking a ranger's
head you feel like the rangers are like
can you not
wait what did he do oh he was trump's
lawyer oh
but he used like shade he did a lot of
[ __ ] and it's like oh he did a lot of
shady [ __ ] for trump and now he's like
the guy turning on trump it's like
he he definitely has a vibe of like this
is my movie and i'm this is the last act
where i've learned my lesson right and
i've done the right thing for my
daughter being like yeah but you're
still kind of a scumbag though yeah yeah
totally he i think he was part of
intimidating like stormy daniels and oh
oh oh oh
a lot of shady [ __ ] did you watch porn
with her by the way i've never seen it
what i feel like you had to for the good
of the country just just to stay
informed yes yes exactly i mean also
it's interesting oh yeah once you see a
lady in the news and you're like i get
to see her
do anal that is interesting it's kind of
fun how does that happen not a big cnn
uh doggy style crossover exactly unless
they start filming anderson cooper am i
right
yeah
he's a vanderbilt
look at that this is a
quite a
voluptuous lady here
figure gal yeah so she i mean she was
playing comedy clubs for a while i know
that really brought us down a peg
i just hate when these guys like fall
into comedy as some kind of last-ditch
effort it is annoying i get that you
want to cash in but does this have to be
the same place that we're working we
worked a really we worked a really long
time together to get good at this so
there was something that's a bummer
about it and i don't even knock her
because you know she's like i'll make 20
grand to do a night or to do an hour or
whatever whatever but like it's the
people go see i'm like who is going to
see stormy daniels do people yeah well
it's people that think it's a funny idea
and then they get there and probably
five minutes and they're like what did
we just waste our money on i think so
because these are people i mean the
president is thinking the same thing
like
165 brands
that was for you to not talk
i got a receipt right
you know trump is kind of like yeah that
was i bit i did pay you yeah did he he
didn't get the money back i'm sure yeah
i'm i wonder if he did a d uh what is a
nda
i think that's what it was oh yeah yeah
he talked mm-hmm
so he could sue
yeah interesting
it's funny remember we had a president
who was like i [ __ ] this porn star it
was a big mistake what was i thinking
she was a trashy [ __ ] anyway and you're
like wow president yeah and he got away
with it yeah well he's off twitter yeah
he's off facebook too so jack dorsey
stepped down i heard yeah
i think this might be the shift for
president trump to come back on twitter
well we'll say we'll see i mean i'm sure
he said he's gonna stay a board member
for uh for a period i'm sure he's gonna
have him but like these people that's
that step down it's it's usually like i
don't want to deal with this i'm sick of
the being the poster boy like part of
part of the fun of being a billionaire
is being a billionaire so you're kind of
like is this fun yeah always being in
trouble like you look at zuckerberg and
you're like senate hearing like you know
you have to talk before like congress or
some [ __ ] like you're like is that fun
well i'm ignorant
what does twitter make a dime
can it make any how
ads
oh i don't see ads on my twitter ads
there's a little promoted really yeah
would you ever see them just says
promoted
also they sell your information yeah ah
no all these apps make money i take it
all back
i make money ignorant no he's worth a
ton of money and there's jack dorsey
look up
look up his net worth i'm sure it's okay
now we're getting somewhere
it's gotta be a hellish she's also one
of the only billionaires with a nose
ring
not a lot of them no he's only worth 11
points what billion
wow and he can't afford a razor
jesus he's a handsome guy he's one of my
favorite members of zz top for sure he
was great in 300.
holy hell did you guys watch the last
episode of succession why i did yeah
dynasty-ish i don't want to spoil
earlier but it was a really good episode
yeah the birthday yeah the birthday one
yeah
that's a good show yeah so good kendall
is so cringy
roman was uh confident which is fun to
watch i think tom is my favorite
character tom's great that guy's an
incredible actor yeah i got a dick like
a sequoia and i [ __ ] like a bullet tray
sorry i mean brian cox i mean they're
all great the whole show is great but
god damn
so good i love that well i don't want to
spoil it
i was gonna say something
too revealing of the plot
succession [ __ ] rules only two
episodes left
yeah this has been fun too
curve i gotta haven't i've i've been
saving i need something to save to just
go through so i've noticed he's been
great it's like a return to the old
style good oh yeah he's fun he's the
best i got a wreck hit me cause uh this
is a little old you might have to do
some googling here
but i took a flight to new orleans
i had the tv
i didn't download any podcast so i had
to stick with the movies love it i go
what is this movie with hugh jackman
i'll give it a shot here we go blah blah
blah it's a three hour flight it's a two
and a half hour movie prisoners i hear
it's dennis villanuev a direction yes
unbelievable i was i was in tears in the
aisle seat i hear it's great
unbelievable it's a little long but i
mean it twists it turns you think it's
this guy
that guy paul daniel's amazing
riddler
what paul daniel's gonna be the riddler
oh there you go
that works yeah that's a good choice
we're doing another batman huh i don't
even know that it's crazy is it is it
bail
no it's robert padden ah
jeez what uh
but you love this movie unbelievable i
showed it to the lady she was like this
is one of the best movies i've ever seen
it's well you watched it again i i made
her watch it i didn't watch it with her
not all the way but i was like you got
to see this because this is true crimey
suspension it's right up her anal and it
was it delivered twice
yeah it's uh jackman's great yeah
jake gyllenhaal has a crazy filmography
for his age like he's in so many good
movies yeah oh yeah it's kind of crazy
when you look at it you're like man his
batting average is like he's like wade
boggs he's just [ __ ] on base every
time zodiac
i just watched a movie with him that
video made me watch it was about you
know the one where they're on a train oh
no forgot the name of it uh
it was good it was like a thriller it
was with uh
really really good actress michelle
monahan isn't it
uh get off my train
uh wrong movie uh what i mean broke back
he's interested
is crazy high i never thought about it
well
boy in the bubble took him down a notch
oh yeah but that was early on october
sky didn't see that way what else
yeah what are you saying can you make it
bigger oh i'm sorry he's in a lot of
movies inside amy schumer oh that's a
great sketch
oh yeah they're like on a blind date
it's funny and they have ferrets it's
funny as [ __ ] ferrets it's really funny
southpaw oh yeah he was a boxer in south
park oh that's good
enemy prisoners loved end of watch i
didn't end of watch is great you love
that movie great cop movie yeah
okay
well there's a lot of [ __ ] i've never
heard of but yeah
it's okay
he's a great director yeah
although you re-watch american beauty it
doesn't really hold up i've heard that
it's a little
uh cartoony annette benning was so hard
in that movie oh did she get plowed huh
by peter gallagher yeah dude um i got a
i got a good movie wreck for you all
right hit me because i'm and look i've
gotten tweets from you guys being like
how the hell was sam not on the
criterion channel i don't know i don't
know how it's eluded me i really don't
know but i've watched some great ones my
wreck is [ __ ] just the director billy
wilder
any billy wilder movie you will be happy
i mean double indemnity is like my
favorite noir ever probably but i'm i've
obviously seen that
watched two in the last week that i'd
never seen what
the original sabrina with humphrey
bogart it's a it's a rom-com it's
[ __ ] great really it's really fun
dude he did sunset boulevard he did he's
a [ __ ] master and yeah some like it
hot yeah he's also a great cop oh the
apartment i mean this guy's who's more
consistent than billy wilder it's crazy
and then uh is he american
i think could be just but i think he
spent time in germany at least at the
very least he worked for a newspaper
which leads to what my
the wreck that i watched
ace in the hole ace in the hole kirk
douglas the movie is basically about a
guy who's a sleazy journalist it's so
timely dude
yeah he's a sleazy journalist who
basically opens by being like i've been
fired from this place i've been fired
from this place and you're like you know
great dialogue out of the gate one of
them like do you drink a lot he goes no
but i drink frequently like just great
dialogue oh nice and basically he he
passes this guy who's stuck
in a cave and they it can't get him out
and he kind kind of orchestrates a way
that the guy will stay stuck in the cave
to turn it into a story and he gets the
rights to tell the whole story because
he knows and there's great dialogue in
it where there's like [ __ ] like um
you know he's with a younger guy who's
kind of his protege and he's like what
about like if it was more people in the
cave and he goes don't you understand
humanist interest it's one person that
people care about because they want to
get to know that person and he's
explaining why this is such a juicy
story interesting and he turns it into a
whole
phenomenon that and it's just
the ugliness of the story yes it's
incredible uh highest name again please
ace in the hole ace in the hole and it's
a billy wilder but you can't go wrong
with any of these
billy wilders man i mean you said it uh
sunset boulevard yeah come on something
like it hot was a
phenomenon yeah he's a master yeah all
right i'm in i love it billy wilder good
call real cinema real
real director here born in
austria-hungary right okay yeah so he
came over i think he was he was a
journalist in germany i believe so i
think that was part of like maybe where
he got the idea for this yes
though and and lemon
what is that one lower lower lower
right there front page now next to it
the fortune cookie i've never heard of
that yeah those two oh my god have you
ever seen stallock 17 i didn't know he
made no it's on there too it's amazing
yeah it's about a a it's a war camp yeah
they're in a war camp that's good it's
great great twists damn he did comedy
and drama that's what's kind of
incredible about him
yeah
all right died in 2002.
wow how old was he 95. it's a good run i
mean i love it yeah hate on 911 chandler
he saw nine away no that's amazing he
was on the plane
no he uh
he and raymond chandler hated each other
they had beef i remember like they
worked on double indemnity together and
i think chandler he was like this guy's
a [ __ ] drunk who doesn't know how to
write movies like he got dialogue but
you know so they just were like this
they wouldn't talk to each other
afterwards i think they were an oscar
for it though but there you go i love
those movie on set beefs you know where
the the writer and the director are
fighting yeah dude that's you don't see
that much anymore uh uh salaccus is a
gift it's my wreck oh
sally baby let it ride
uh-oh it's also a gift for this dude
wait a minute wait a minute you know
it's going to be something pretentious
if it's from
the red
balloon wow dustin hoffman tear this
lenny wow oh
the acting is amazing yeah i think he
was nominated for this i believe so he
got nominated for everything right 60s
70s he was always nominated whoa oh
that's a great post this must have cost
you a hundred dollars 20 bucks all right
it's pretty cool man
look at that and then a beauty
that's pretty dope a great photo too
that's almost too big to put up no we
can get it we'll find a place on the
back of the door
i love it yeah honey bruce
it's also my recommendation for the
movie to watch
good call good it's a good movie it is a
good movie i haven't seen in years
all right let me give you a peeve
stop me if i've given you that thank you
this is very nice i want to put in my
house
um
i hope i haven't done this one before
but we're all tied down you know
three ladies amongst us you ever get
this one
the
we
when she means you
you know like we need to change the
garbage
and before i know i'm like oh yeah i'm
like tying it up i'm pulling i'm like
what do you mean we you mean you say we
need to get off our period
boom yeah bulger had a great dan bulger
had a great bit about it he's like she's
like we need to do this he's like no no
no she goes you need to do this he goes
we have
herpes something like that
i hate the wii well we need new sheets
which means like you should get some new
sheets right it's she's giving you
orders in a in a way that's just it's
she's disguising orders disguising
orders yeah and now i do the move where
i go yeah yeah get on that
hitler used to do this says we need to
get you in a concentration camp
yeah what do we have to do today to get
you yeah we need to see your papers no
we uh you know
i'm with you man the classic girl thing
just say uh somebody's got to change the
garbage but it's also like oh do you
want the garbage just change it what is
this what are you putting it out in the
world for if you want to change just
change it that's how i would do it why
don't you say hey do you mind changing
or that cause we just we just want the
honesty yes just give it to me straight
sister yeah
we
need to clean the litter out the cat
litter like
now i know it's about you
i [ __ ] in the cat like a truck look at
[ __ ] in the sand
which i'm sure it's fun you ever heard
that old clooney story what oh
man he was living with some guy back
when he was broke
and uh
i think he's a goofy took a [ __ ] in the
litter box like a big fat smelly human
[ __ ] and the guy came home was like
jesus christ this cat and like they put
it down
what give it a [ __ ] i'm i'm i'm
butchering jesus christ it's a famous
clooney's cat story you guys should
worry less about darfur and more about
uh cat fur
yeah was he a darfur guy yeah yeah that
was a that was his cause oh [ __ ]
now he's got a uh accomplished wife yeah
i'm all i'm all i'm all out of love
i like the picture is him like looking
very dignified in a beard george clooney
one [ __ ] in the cat tray there it is oh
i can't believe you found it the toronto
sun is out of news but is the only
academy award winner to [ __ ] in a
letterbox
this is breaking unless garfield won one
am i wrong i had a tale of twin twin
kitties
the tale of two kitties all right give
me give me the punch line of that
because it's a hell of a story you might
have do a little reading there fatty but
uh it's a it's a killer story and it's
fun knowing this guy's an academy award
winner he's helping darfur he's
plowing a uh established lady and he's
still [ __ ] in a box
he's got a new thing coming out with uh
affleck and matt damon oh really yeah
hmm
well he also sold it tequila which we're
trying to do yeah we got to get that go
fat cat's still in the works folks legal
mumbo jumbo but fat cat's coming make
sure to email us to it we might be drunk
pod gmail.com and sign up for that
patreon we got a lot of [ __ ] coming your
way oh
yeah
you better believe it and send us
anything gotham studios uh 39 west 38th
street new york new york whatever the
hell the zip code is
and uh you'll find it on the on the web
now what do you got for a bit i got a
couple ideas let me try this one out all
righty i wrote one down
hit me
one more time when i argue with my
girlfriend there's the idea it's kind of
like a bad action movie like each one is
over two hours there's lots of
explosions by the end you're like what
was the point of that
you know what i mean oh yeah so it's
like then she'll revisit the fight in a
year that's the sequel
women aren't reopening old fights
they're trying to build a franchise yeah
i call it the slow and the furious ah i
was just thinking fast and furious is
there something there yeah i like that i
would say blow up instead of explosion
because there's no explosion in here the
fight is a blow up we had to pull up
exactly and i might say and it was uh
two hours i'll never get back there's a
big blow up ooh that's good that's what
people say after a bad movie yeah
there's two outs i'll never get back
yeah there's a big blow up
that's good there's something there i
love a good uh analogy with a rule of
threes that's that's good stuff there's
two hours i'll never get back think of
more and i like the fast and the furious
kind of sounds like you in the bedroom
i'm too finished too fast she's furious
all right uh yeah there's something
about like bad movie yeah and you're
just kind of like
terminator
uh yeah and then maybe something about
like this was your idea
right oh you know when someone picks a
bad movie yeah what's the equivalent of
a chick flick like you're getting back
together you have to watch a one of her
movies now
so yeah there's something about like um
yeah you're you're fighting as an action
movie she wants to live more like a
rom-com and you're trying to get into a
porn at the end oh there we go
movie movie movie yeah that's a movie
yes so now it's like now we have to yeah
maybe the the therapist is the critic
he's like the movie critic you know
going like well you know you made some
mistakes here or whatever i don't know
there's something about like yeah then
we got to make it work
trying to think about how to there's
something i'm new to with this what do
you got
well the funny thing too is
well now i'm going too deep into it uh
damn yeah
all right all right i like this
the director trying the director
could have read the cliff's notes
all right all right hold on what do you
got the book was better
all right
uh okay here we go pulling up my [ __ ]
now is this too stupid
um
so i have a cat
and a lot of people will [ __ ] on cats
around me not knowing i have a cat
and they'll [ __ ] on cats and it almost
feels like i'm dating a minority and
they don't know it and so we'll be at a
bar and they're like oh yeah i hate cats
i don't trust them they're the worst and
i'm kind of like
i live with one you know
that's a great line i live with one i
have to let them know eventually like
well you know it's like they're they
don't trust them they're racist or
whatever
um
like uh you know victor varnado who is a
funny comic he's an albino yeah and he
has he always said people would say the
n-word around him because they didn't
know he was black wow and so he would
just have to live with that or like
fight the guy or whatever it was
and that's kind of how i'm not comparing
but uh
i just feel like people [ __ ] on cats i'm
like sitting here like i like i live
with a cat you [ __ ] i love i live with
one it's so because it sounds so
defensive like uh
yeah i mean the idea that like i mean my
mind goes to like people have said
anti-semitic [ __ ] to me and be like oh
you're a jew right perfect exactly like
yeah like i'm a jew
but it's funny about like and they they
dial back or they they pull back like oh
i didn't know you had one i don't mean
all cats you know it just sounds like
they're they're uh backpedaling but dude
but you know what it's funny maybe if
they don't it's like with it with
race they usually apologize with kasha
like yeah i don't know what to tell you
i don't like a dog
and dogs are kind of like white people
everybody likes them they
you know people like cats they don't do
anything they sit around all day not
asians yeah good point what here's
what's interesting is like
why do we do that with we don't do that
with humans you're like you're like do
you like blacks i'm a filipino person
you know what i mean why do we do that
why why do you have to choose cats or
dogs i love them i like them both why
can't you like them both good point
why do we like why like this instead
yeah and they talk about it like a race
like i didn't grow up with them maybe
aliens would do that with humans they're
just like do you like blind people like
no i'm with a white guy that's the pets
they have you know oh yeah yeah
yeah i don't know it feels like there's
something here
also black cat is like spooky you know
there's all kinds of weird parallels
i've never heard anybody say they hate
dogs
yeah usually when people say i hate dogs
like i don't like animals so you're
right
i hear people are afraid of dogs that
could be hate dogs they're just afraid i
don't like that trumps hate fear hate
trump's hate people have a hate of
visceral hatred for cats yeah people
[ __ ] hate cats some people love cats
yeah i think the one thing is like the
way it's different from a race is like
there's no race of people that makes you
get hives
like people are allergic to cats oh
right right you break out yeah you're
like [ __ ] you're like oh geez do you
have an asian here do you have any
benadryl
yeah
yeah that would be really racist if your
body was physically
couldn't be around asians
someone you know what i'm thinking i
don't know yeah yeah i just think
there's a parallel no no with minority
and cats the line i like the best right
now is um
i live with juan i live i live with like
you getting offended yes
yes exactly
yeah people hate cats they're open about
cats hating them
uh dogs are happy go lucky
fun
can i ask you about a bit of yours
i saw a clip of one of your bits it was
the uh shooting jeff bezos into space oh
yeah yeah i really think there's
something there really how did it go
i don't remember was it was something
about how like oh how
this bit was something like how he keeps
going into space and they were like what
they should have done
is um
they should shoot yeah they should put
them on the rock and just tell them tell
them to send it to mars but just send it
to afghanistan this is like at the
height of the afghanistan thing and it
gets off and he's like holy [ __ ] like
martians are so primitive you know
they're just throwing that but then i
think the tournament was like but then
he would start amazon in afghanistan
and treat his workers horrible uh
and then he would find out that his
harsh treatment would still be better
than how afghanis treat women
that was the turn
that's good
but it's a long way to go i might have
to just shorten it like maybe the angle
is more like we talk about how bezos
like pregnant women in the factory but
then you're like
then they're like
uh you know isis they're gonna go oh you
know they're like well we already do
that the taliban we already do that
right right we already treat women that
way
he's like our villain
but it's really clever i don't know if
there's anything there i think i think
he's overrating the bit i think it's
like a meh you know
[Music]
maybe something about how we can't get
people out of afghanistan but if we
boxed them up and i feel like we can get
them the next day
like delivery
too hard overnight overnight yeah maybe
bezos is next line i would think more
like mexico he's a he's a kyoti
that's who we get he gets people here in
his boxes yeah and it's it's also weird
that we can't get afghanis here but yet
we can get to space
you know that's why yeah were you
telling me something about kim
kardashian getting afghanis here yeah
give it a go what's that story she sent
a jumbo jet to afghanistan and saved a
bunch of people it's interesting too
it's like to be like because it's kind
you got to be kind of ballsy to like
underpay your workers yeah and show up
in a nice car bezos underpays his
employees and went to space
right
that's crazy
that's true
kim kardashian a rabbi helped afghan
teenage girls soccer players get safely
to britain there you go
see
she gets a bad rap oh she couldn't pass
the bar
130 people including 30 teenage players
look at that 130 yes pretty good if i
was a billionaire i mean i say this but
i would be doing this kind of [ __ ] it'd
be fun
i mean a rabbit people the rabbi was the
other person who's the rabbi he's
getting good he doesn't even get a shout
out yeah
all right
let's plug some dates all right all
right i'd like to
play some music underneath you talking
oh please oh i sent you this song yeah
this is great winter music yeah i like
a little ben webster great saxophonist
all
isn't that nice
i'm just gonna leave this on my
apartment this is perfect winter it's
christmasy oh i bought a tree you buy a
tree yet
taylor baldwin it's the best feeling
we bought one yeah we bought it
all right
did you get a big middle
she bought two two
yeah that's a little rubbing in the face
on the jewel it is she got a menorah too
all right all right
so we bought a menorah but she got
she got uh
she got two and uh it was funny she
tried to play off like she's like that's
how much i love christmas i bought two i
was like
you could have just had one note she's
like it was i can't they i don't know
how to cancel the delivery
like she was like that's how into
christmas like now you've made a mistake
yeah don't do that with the adoption
agency
i couldn't send it back what do you got
i got a
charlotte comedy zone i think i'm
nipping at your heels over there i'm at
the buckhead theater in atlanta
about to sell out hopefully we can add a
show there it's a big room
uh
syracuse funny bone my milwaukee improv
toronto at the dark comedy festival
uh
those dates are wrong kansas city improv
um got all kinds of fun dates coming up
go to
marknormancomedy.com
this comes out the 12th right matt
okay so i got um
i got dallas this weekend addison improv
i got in january i'm going to add more
if i can but right now i've got richmond
uh january 20th through 22nd i've got
mcgoobies in uh timonium
maryland the 27th through 29th and
and then uh
february hartford and sacramento
and more coming
as well as big one coming new york city
if you're listening beacon theater in
may that should be on sale tomorrow so i
hope you come out
beacon baby
chris big deal so i hope you guys show
out for that because that's like new
york city kid very big deal very excited
about that one so i hope i hope everyone
uh i mean that's a milestone yeah i'm
excited so please come out i'd love to
sell it holy hell
beacon make seven i'm a little nervous
now i'm intimidated why i can't hang out
with you anymore you could do it i can't
do it
i can't maybe i'll pop by pop by can i
be in the green room is that weird i'd
be honored all right all right wow
beacon
simon jerry seinfeld samurail oh yeah
well
make sure we sell it out first but uh
honored if you guys would buy tickets i
believe it goes on sale tomorrow holy
3200 seats i think it's 2 900. okay
yeah all right you got that
29 baby hey you've sold out of eight
caroline's in a row a conversation oh
got them i'm sorry yeah but no i hope
you guys come out and this [ __ ] song
is great i love so good ben webster if
you guys haven't listened to ben webster
you'll love him he's incredible oh yeah
that is some good good tunes thank you
everybody keep drinking happy holidays
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you